on va parler tout de suite à bertrand
serriérois dans l'émission bertrand
charme au match à mon roi qui revient
c'est parti bon bertrand d'amour est ce
que tu peux nous donner la météo quand
même avec plaisir demain matin le temps
sera pluvieux dans le
dans le principe le kart les cartes ce
serait génial à dublin n'a plus vu dans
le nord dans le quart sud ouest ne météo
que je qualifierais personnellement de
mossad a livré ses premières m'étais par
cult ailleurs globalement on est sur du
beau temps du côté des températures des
valeurs de saison comprises entre 10 la
minimale mulhouse montélimar la maximale
sera pour perpignan avec 19 degrés
l'après midi
une flèche rouge attaquera marseille où
il va on est sur les gas salut
mais me dis que c'est le vent autant
pour moi c'est une fois vers vous l'avez
vu bref une france à deux vitesses du
gris du jeune en fonction de votre lieu
d'habitation 20 degrés à lille 26 à nice
30 à toulouse et 25
ça replonge dans l' achat d'or noir nous
serons le mardi 4 septembre et nous
fêterons les rosalies bonne fête à tous
les fans de carlos don
[Applaudissements]
hélas
hier trois caméras qui avait tout fait
[Applaudissements]